foreign
this isn't fair this isn't fair yeah
hold on there we go we changed the
camera uh situation
we don't have it on tripod anymore it's
now just sticking on the top on the top
yeah we just clipped it to the laptop so
it's a little bit cool we didn't know we
have a clip on there we had that thing
on a whole [__] it's just dumb
because I'm just kind of like I'm
looking of course because they all kind
of do but we're looking at the bottom of
that it says look at that little line
running around the bottom of it looks
like a clip oh yeah
yeah much better well because yeah
because last night we were moving stuff
around
we had it on a bigger tripod yeah and
then we were like well this tripod
situation behind the laptop was not
working so yeah this is working out
better yeah we're a little closer to the
camera but that's okay yeah we're closer
to the camera that's what it is isn't it
yeah yeah that's why that's why I was
like
yeah Uber in the other video
yeah always in the other video yeah yeah
I have to back up a little bit all right
gotta readjust to the new new reality
yeah
uh Oscar said I saw this on Hulu the
other day it was good albeit a little
aimless
um I actually loved this movie I think
this
I mean all of three of Brandon
cronenberg's movies I've seen them all
and every single one of them is good I
think this might be my favorite one and
actually I kind of want to re-watch it
because I've been thinking about it ever
since we watched it when did we watch it
Thursday night yeah it was weird
I mean it's Brandon Cronenberg it's
gonna be weird it's definitely a
Cronenberg movie it's not like his dad
his dad's body horror type
this is a different kind of horror it's
it's body horror but it's I think it's
psychological too
yeah it's weird and it's I guess it's
nominally sci-fi although I mean I guess
because it kind of has stuff to do with
cloning but it does it's not really
um
like real science heavy you know what I
mean because there is cloning in it but
the the you know parameters and the
logistics of the cloning are not really
a focus they're just kind of like hand
wavy yeah because it's really more about
like the philosophical implications of
the cloning I thought it was a quality
movie
eyes like I said I thought it was great
I was just I was just riveted from the
very beginning yeah I loved everything
about it I loved the shot compositions I
love the score
um I just what a great [__] concept
this was and I mean and I'm not saying
that it's other movies because I loved
possessor and I really liked uh
antiviral which was his first one and
that came out back in 2012 which is also
really good but I think this is my
favorite one that he's done so far and
it seems like I don't know like I was I
kind of sampled a you know uh did a
sampling of like different reviews of it
most horror people seem to really like
it
um a couple of them were just kind of
like oh it was too weird or they didn't
get it
um and but most critics seemed like real
positive about it you know what I mean
yeah I don't know how much we can say
about the movie it's still pretty new I
mean we can't spoil anything I mean it
came out in January so it's been out for
like six months this was actually
probably my most anticipated movie for
of 2023 at least one of the most
anticipated so I was glad that I finally
got around to seeing it but yeah it's
like how much I kind of remember the
trailer and I'm trying to think of like
what the trailer shows yeah which is
like what they want you to kind of know
going into it right and it's like you
don't yeah you don't really want to
spoil it but I don't know I kind of feel
like other reviewers have like said
what's kind of going on in the movie I
can do a quick like high testosterone
[__] summary of the damn thing oh my
God this will suck dudes right here okay
yeah [__] like that okay it's about two
couples
on vacation in this other country it's
like an island yeah it's a fictional
it's a fictional island though and uh
they got some weird ass laws there you
know they consider the laws to be
barbaric like if you commit a crime
you get into custody you found guilty
that the other family has the right
to take extract Vengeance out on you you
know if you did something to to one of
their family members
well they go there and the guy's a
writer and uh his wife uh is a cute
light-skinned chick
and she's got all the money she's
supporting his ass and they run into
another couple who's like a swinger
couple it's a kind of a cool older dude
with his super freaks yeah yeah his cool
older dude with his hot young wife and
the young wife is just laying it all
thick trying to just climb up this
[__] just trying to climb up this
this author's dick you know and she's
doing it right in front of the husband
the husband's like yeah yeah he doesn't
really give a [__] get it Mia yeah yeah
you guys have fun he's like that kind of
[__] well
the two couples go out there party and
they're having a good time and they're
riding around in a Cadillac at night in
the middle of the night and [__] the
the the writer guy
um they were all drinking all right but
the writer guy was I guess the the least
the least drunk so he decided to drive
and accidentally hit a dude [__]
crossing the street in the middle of the
night out in the middle of the [__]
woods and they leave the [__] body
there and everything just run
but they catch him at it they catch his
ass anyway
and they hand him over to the [__]
family
all right the legal system hands him
over the family and that's really kind
of where
the fun the weird part of the Story
begins because there's a way out of this
[__] if you have the money if you have
the money and that involves cloning
yeah
if you can make a clone in yourself
they can kill the Clone and you'd get
you could walk scot-free
so that happens
and then those two couples they had all
this money
they start going on [__]
getting off on this a [__] committing
crimes and then making CR making their
clones pay for it yeah that's what the
movies basically about yeah it's kind of
basically exploring that's like well if
if you had all the money and this was a
real thing like that you could clone
somebody that and the Clone is not like
just some brain in a tank or anything
like that it's an actual copy of you
that has all your memories and and all
your emotions and everything exactly
like you yeah it thinks it's you right
and so like you right and the and the
[__] up thing too is that you know
yeah if you pay to get this clone made
or whatever and you have to watch them
get executed
um in a real brutal way uh you have to
watch it that's like part of the law too
and your memory of committing the crime
gets erased too well see I don't know if
it was just erased or because I thought
that they said that but then I was like
oh maybe not maybe
um because I I didn't know if that kind
of like maybe I have to go back and
watch it again because I had the clothes
captioning on and I thought that that's
what they said but then later on I was
like wait a minute maybe that's not what
they said because I thought that maybe
that kind of um factored into the story
later on as to why these people that had
been doing this I mean essentially so
like these rich people come to this
island knowing that this is the law and
they're like oh we're gonna go on
another murder vacation because they can
just like do whatever the [__] they want
to and they just pay to have a clone die
for them and then they get off on the
then they start getting off on watching
their clones pay for the [__] crimes
right it's almost like [__] up it's
almost like live action snuff it is what
it is yeah yourself right and and your
your girlfriend and your wife and you're
all clapping and why they're slitting
their throats and [__] and [__]
it's weird man what a great [__]
concept I just love the concept but they
just I wish I thought yeah more and more
evil with this yeah like their their
souls are just like completely
disintegrated and the the movie is kind
of asking that question too like how
you know what would that do to a person
like knowing that just watching
themselves essentially like get killed
like
was the cloning process the physical
cloning process was it extracting
something out of them were they getting
worse because they were see that's what
I was wondering too
right and then and then what ended up
happening is that the ones that were
being killed was the real them and the
[__] Originals started to slowly
become the Clown see yeah that's another
thing because that was another like
implication of it yeah you have to see
it a couple times there may be some
there may be some some hints in there
that but this is It's a Cronenberg movie
it takes a couple times to and you know
I know it's his dad it's really kind of
[__] set the standard
but it's still they're in the same
universe let's just say that these
movies are all kind of in the same
universe they're different styles he's
not copying his dad but he you can see
it's heavy influence he's just
continuing his dad's work but his own
way it's good [__] man I mean he's good
he's good yeah I pretty much I loved
everything about this yeah it's crazy to
me because the lead character James who
is the writer
he's played by Alexander Skarsgard and I
had forgotten that that's the same dude
from the northmen and it's crazy to me
because this is like yeah but this is
like a completely opposite character
when he played in the north man I mean
in the Northman he was this big bulky
um you know badass and in this he's kind
of like
he seems like kind of like a broken man
you know what I mean he's kind of like
even from the beginning he's just kind
of like I don't want to say pitiful but
he's just kind of like he's riding on
the coattails of his wife I mean his
wife has all the money
um she basically straight up tells
everybody right in front of him that she
married him because she has daddy issues
and because her dad her Rich Dad didn't
like him yeah and and he's like a bum so
he wrote one book because her dad runs
like a publishing company that published
the dude's book right yeah and so and
then it got horrible reviews like they
were talking about how stupid or
pretentious it was and he hasn't been
able to like write another one for like
six years and that was the reason that
they went on this vacation so he could
get like some inspiration and write
another one but you can tell that his
wife is just like has absolutely no
respect for him whatsoever and he's like
almost kind of like resigned to it like
he doesn't have a lot of dialogue and
this Alexander Skarsgard but you can
tell like just the way he's treated like
a loser yeah you know what I mean and
it's and it's just kind of like and it's
almost kind of like so MIA character who
is um you know the the woman half of the
crazy swinger couple yeah she almost
like sees that and it's like oh we're
gonna Target this [__] you know
what I mean because it's there's a crazy
[__] scenes in this that one scene
where he was like where they kind of go
out of this compound because like I said
they go to this it's not it's a
fictional country they actually shot
this in Croatia like at a resort in
Croatia but um it's a fictional country
yeah [__] all these Sensational what you
said fictional it didn't sound like you
said fictional yeah I thought [__]
holders it's a [__] no I'm pretty sure I
said fictional yeah unless I'm happy I
was swallowing at the same time oh okay
so maybe you didn't hear it right I mean
I'm perfectly willing to think that
maybe I said it wrong
it's situational yeah but um that's like
something situational but also shitty at
the same time but uh yeah so it's like a
fictional country and the the
implication being I don't even know if
it's an implication because they kind of
say this out right but it's like it's
got all these like super fancy Resorts
that all these super wealthy people hang
out at but outside of these compounds
which have like barbed wire and guards
and all this other kind of [__] like the
country is really really poor and so
like a lot of the residents of this
country don't actually like all these
[__] wealthy people just showing up
and doing whatever the [__] they want to
um because they can because of the law
you know what I mean so there's some of
that like tension going on as well so
it's almost kind of like not only
examining James's character and his just
like maybe maybe his self-loathing
getting to a point where he just gets
pulled Along on this adventure if you
want to call it that
um but also there's kind of like a
larger implication about these people
that are wealthy and it's just like they
can get away with whatever they want and
they're just like running roughshod over
everybody like not in this country but
you know what I mean like at this
country like all the locals and stuff
but you know they're just murdering
people and like breaking into people's
houses and stealing their [__] and
everything they don't need to obviously
but it's just kind of like they get so
off on being able to do it and not
having any consequences and then just
and they're also seem to be getting kind
of almost like a sexual charge out of
watching themselves get executed yeah
like every time like it's like it's
almost like a big charge for them yeah
they're clapping and cheering right like
ever like they're like oh like do a real
[__] up one like it'll get you know
what I mean so it's almost kind of like
so I feel like Brandon Cronenberg is
kind of exploring similar themes to
David kronenberg but it's slightly
different you know yeah I feel like
there's like a slight difference this is
always kind of and I think I mentioned
this on
uh Friday show when we talked about this
a little bit I said I I read like a
review of this movie that actually kind
of nailed it they said whereas like
David kernenberg was more worried about
bodily disintegration or bodily
desecration
um whereas Brandon Cronenberg is more
worried about like Soul desecration yeah
because it's almost like
every time this happens like every time
they do this in this movie they're a
little piece of their Humanity like is
frittered away it's good man I yeah I
[__] grew up watching Cronenberg
movies I you know I think the first one
I ever saw was the The Brood and I was a
kid in that [__] that's still one of
my favorites yeah man I love that movie
that one was [__] awesome and uh
scared the [__] out of me and then saw
video drone
and uh I saw all of I've seen I think
all David cronenberg's movies I don't
think you've seen some of the newer ones
like I don't think you've seen like
Eastern Promises or History of Violence
or anything but then we saw that the
last one spider we saw that one in the
theaters
the future is pretty good pretty good
um
but uh his son Brandon he's gonna come
and he's gonna kind of continue that
work I mean what else could he do what's
he gonna do
and you're gonna what do children's
stories you know you're gonna make
episodes of My Little Pony
if you have the last name cronerberg
remember how good scatters was man I
love that one too man yeah uh no you're
gonna have to do something like a dad to
stay
relevant but you have to do it your own
way and I think he's doing it well the
thing about it too I was watching a
video earlier and like the reviewer was
kind of like I think a little bit
unfairly
um talking about oh well why don't all
of these because she was also comparing
like Brandon Cronenberg and David
Cronenberg to like you know Stephen King
and Joe Hill like his son the novelist
and it's like oh you know why don't they
carve out their own identities or like
you know instead of doing the same thing
that their dad did but I was like well
the thing about it is
well well no it's not just that but it's
like it's it might like be in their DNA
it's like they have the same DNA so it's
like obviously they're gonna have a lot
of similarities in that regard and it's
like it's it's like well if Joe Hill for
example like his writing is kind of like
Stephen King's writing but that's his
dad you know what I mean like he grew up
around like I said they share DNA so
it's like it'd be really weird if he
came out and like deliberately tried to
write something like completely
completely different that wasn't like
natural to him you know what I mean like
it seems like it's natural for him to
write that way just like it was natural
for his dad to write that way so it's
like why pretend to be something else
just because people would be like oh
it's too much like your dad's you know
what I mean it's like I don't know it's
kind of like I can I can see like
but they're related it's like it seems I
don't know it just it just seems kind of
unreasonable to ask them to deliberately
go out of their way to be completely
different if that's not something that
comes naturally to them you get what I'm
saying I don't know so it just seemed
like a weird criticism and like I said
the thing about it is no it is that's a
standard [__] ass criticism it is like
I said I don't I don't know I just
thought that was really that's
unreasonable I thought it was
unreasonable if you've got one author
and he's he's got a [__] really built
fan base and you grew up around him he's
your dad you understand where he's
coming from you you're gonna go yeah
okay I can I can do that too I can I'm
gonna do it a little bit different
but your fan base will like this one too
what I'm doing and then you can kind of
like because you know I'll I'll watch
either one of those those guys movies I
think they're good yeah you know now
you're never gonna recapture what it was
like back in the 80s to see [__]
scanners right the world was different
back then yeah it's all a matter of
content yeah the context and
she's like in in those days you know we
didn't have access to just instant
visual media
yeah you had to go to the movies or see
television for that now people just walk
around with their phones and they can
see a fantastic imagery moving you know
they're kind of
I think people are kind of especially
younger people are kind of deadened to
it they don't they don't inventory
doesn't really mean much to them
but that was [__] badass back in the
80s if you see a dude [__] think
another dude to death where it [__]
caused his head to blow up that was some
imagery I never thought of that and
that's you know his head blow up you're
like oh whoa and you didn't forget it
blew that dude's head up like in the
first five minutes yeah
and then they're using mental powers and
stuff and you know just a crazy idea but
it was it was just compelling
you didn't forget it and then it brewed
same way
so um yeah of course
of course uh his dad kind of had in some
ways I think a little bit of an easier
Mission because the public wasn't as
jaded
you know yeah and not as many things
existed so now
you're not gonna be able to like
I don't think you'll ever well you'll
never be able to top that in my mind
because I saw that when I was a little
kid and made an impression on me and
there wasn't anything like compete with
it back then like now it's so hard to
stand out because because you know we've
talked about this before because of the
internet and like pretty much anybody
with a connection can like create
something and upload it so there's so
much stuff in my opinions of of
cronenberg's old movies back in the 80s
were based upon my reactions to it then
yeah I'm remembering the way I felt felt
back then right I mean that's just the
way it is you know I could go back and
watch a lot of those movies they still
stand up I don't know if a younger
person could see them for the first time
and see the same things in them they
seemingly can do that with like Predator
one and T1 they can because they're just
so Elemental so simple those stories I
don't know how I had to go look on
YouTube and seeing young young people
yeah it'd be kind of interesting
reactions to things like scanners
yeah and The Brood
you know to see what they think about
sometimes young people see it they just
instantly get it oh yeah that's some
creepy [__]
you know some people just some younger
people are looking at it that's dumb you
know yeah I guess it would depend on
them yeah but you know and we've talked
about this a lot because that's kind of
like an interesting thing to me like the
context of the time it does seem like a
lot of horror movies though a lot of
younger fans will watch like older ones
and dig them like and kind of have the
same reaction that we had I had the same
reaction to [__] seeing
the black cat
from Boris Karloff and Bella Lugosi back
in the 30s you know what I mean I think
I had a maybe a little bit of a better
reaction probably than the people back
then yeah I saw it I thought that was a
[__] bizarre flick
a really good flick that talking about
and damn
necrophilia and [__]
stealing people's [__] wives and
daughters and Satanism and
torture and
and it's all right there it's just it's
not
really spelled out you just have to real
you just got to go okay I know what he's
talking about yeah he's keeping these
dead women in these [__] coffins
because it keeps them beautiful
it's he got to be having sex with them
it must be why you know what I mean yeah
but again I'm coming at you didn't say
that but that's probably what it is you
know and I would think people in the 30s
maybe a lot of people in the 30s maybe
that didn't cross their minds that he
was having because they weren't big
perverts they couldn't take that leap
maybe yeah because I couldn't as a kid I
didn't when I when I saw it as a lot
younger it did I didn't realize that
right but later as I got a little bit
older I was like wait oh wait a minute
those are probably sex dolls yeah yeah
no we know now studying these serial
killers these [__] dudes digging up
dead people and [__] yeah people get all
kind of interesting ideas
like well never thought of that okay
uh subjective perspective Collective
says hey y'all I love every Cronenberg
film can't say the same for Carpenter
Romero Hooper and Craven that's true I
do kind of feel like as much as I love
all of those directors yeah some of them
did have a couple of uh of stinkers in
there but Cronenberg every single
Cronenberg movie and I might have seen
them all now that I'm thinking about it
every single one has been good and worth
watching I don't think Carpenter made
all those movies I think some of those
really stink bombs I don't think he made
like I don't think he made [__]
ghosts to Mars
I think somebody else made that I kind
of want to watch that again even though
I remember really not liking it that was
cool there was nothing carpenter-ish
about that
if he did he just didn't give a [__]
yeah he's just like whatever yeah after
they [__] him over with the thing he
started to be like ah [__] it yeah a
little bitter about that but I can't say
I blame him to be honest because that's
a [__] brilliant movie although
[__] Christine was after and it was
great
I feel like people don't talk about that
one I really really like a really good
Carpenter and I think like people don't
talk about it and they're good fake
Carpenter flicks like vhw or VFW VFW
yeah that carbon had nothing to do with
that but that [__] feels like a
carpenter movie well yeah it's
definitely homage yeah like particularly
Assault on Precinct 13 yeah is what
they're homaging but like score sounds
like Carpenter yeah
um but yeah so so that's the thing I I
just kind of feel like I'm Into You know
I was into David cronerberg and I really
like
the fact that his son is continuing it's
interesting because Oscar just said that
he thought that um the that this was too
similar to Crimes of the future
like too similar in tone ice I get what
you're saying but I don't know I don't
know if it was similar enough to and
honestly it's and this might be a
controversial opinion I'm not entirely
sure I think I liked this better than
crimes Crimes of the future crimes the
future had that we had weird special
effects though body stuff happened and
growing that's true uh they're different
this one has body horror but not in the
same way like I said this is more
psychological it does have some [__]
up like violence and [__] like that and
I'm not saying that like somebody
getting their head beaten in repeatedly
uh someone getting stabbed repeatedly
um this cut yeah throats cut stuff like
that so it does have like Gore and it is
kind of graphic this is also pretty well
I don't know if I'd call it sexually
graphic
um but it does have some scenes in it
that now I think the version that we
watched which is on Hulu I think a few
scenes were trimmed out of that like to
get an R because originally this the
movie was rated nc17 I'm pretty sure
that if you rent it on YouTube you can
rent the uncut one I think all they took
out was I think there was like a [__]
shot
like a penis like jerking because
there's a scene there's a [__] scene
basically
um and I think they showed like part of
it and it was kind of like implied and
then like they kind of show but they
don't show it the the semen coming out
of the dick but I think in the uncut
version they do at least that's what I
heard this also has like a lot of real
psychedelic imageries because there's
this drug that it's you know I guess is
fictional but you kind of like put it in
a bowl and you sniff it and it gives you
all these crazy like [__]
hallucinations and stuff so there's like
a lot of hallucinatory orgy type of
stuff going on in that in this too so
there is kind of like more body horror
stuff like David kornenberg but it's not
exactly the same it's not it's not like
the same thing as like oh I have a
vagina in my stomach you know what I
mean it's not quite that it's more like
I don't know I kind of feel like it's
maybe more like David cronenberg's newer
stuff or but it's also its own thing I
think Brandon Cronenberg is going more
whereas David cronenberg's I feel like
his are more clinical
um whereas I think
um Brandon kronerbergs are more lurid
and more like psychedelic you know what
I mean a little bit because I think
possessor had a lot of that kind of acid
trippy imagery in it too and anti-viral
did too if I'm remembering correctly
it's been a while since I've seen that
but so it's definitely a different thing
and can we talk about [__] Sexes he
likes the Harry Potter
oh yeah thanks I got those four yeah I
thought they they kind of went with this
wig yeah they're like little 30s [__]
goofy girl glass [__] so you're
you're telling me I look goofy yeah what
do you call them little uh nerds little
nerdy girl nerd yeah yeah it's cool
though thank you that's okay I can be a
nerd yeah
glasses but yeah Mia goth is great in
this um I kind of feel like she's been
getting a lot of the attention well [__]
man Mia goth I I don't think uh until I
saw this movie because I think she
because she's English right and I didn't
realize I think I knew she was English
but I didn't really think about it
because every other movie I've seen her
in
she was playing an American you know I
saw her in X and she played An American
in that and then she you know she was in
Pearl also which I still haven't seen
yet I need to see that and she was also
in um a cure for wellness it wasn't like
a huge part that was back in 2016. but I
don't think that I've seen her
with her real voice so I was kind of
like weirded out I was like oh my God
that's must be her real voice like what
she talks like man she is um
kind of terrifying in this she's really
kind of over the top I really respect
though that she picks these [__]
weird ass roles I mean maybe she's like
a super freak in real life you know what
I mean that's what I've had and like all
the people in the horror Community are
just like all about it she's like the
new horror scream Queen because she is
like in some [__] she'll be in
just the craziest [__] horror movies
and she seems to like really get into it
but yeah she is um
this is a great role for her she's just
like [__] she goes for it man there's
just like all kind of like I said I
loved her in X as well and everybody
says that I need to see Pearl which is
like the prequel to X you would probably
like X too
but um I can't remember what streaming
platform it's on I watched it and I
don't think I paid for it so it's
probably on there so what you would
probably like it like I said it's a
slasher but it's set back in the 70s and
it's like all of these people that go
They're gonna go film a porno like back
in the 70s and then like somebody starts
killing all of them but it's it's really
good like it has like this really cool
like retro look to it and everything and
it's super super violent like super gory
I was like really into it
um Zach says the first thing I saw Mia
Gotham was that large von Trier movie
Lars montreier blur smart tree or
whatever his name is uh nymphomaniac
where she pisses on Shia LaBeouf see
that's what I mean that was like the for
I think that was her first big movie I
don't know if it was her first movie
movie but that was like the first one
that she got attention for and I still
haven't seen that
um yeah she's married to Shia LaBeouf
and they're both nuts yeah yeah she
definitely does come across as like
someone but like I said I like that she
picks these
out their roles and you know I just I
don't know I just really like that about
her she really does seem like she'd be a
super freak in real life you know what I
mean and she's definitely a super freak
in this movie because of like the whole
that whole hand job scene I was like oh
okay we're going this way now okay
and uh you know it was just kind of like
a whole weird situation and I just loved
Alexander skars cards [__] face like
when it started happening he just like
had no idea what to do like he just
[__] stated they're going holy [__]
what the [__] is happening right now
it's just like he didn't try to stop it
or nothing he was just kind of I don't
know it was just like a weird [__]
scene but yeah like I said I didn't want
to spoil too much about it but it's
really hard to talk about this movie
without talking about
what it's about although I will say that
I'm glad that I went into it basically
all I knew about the movie was that it
was Brandon Cronenberg and who was in it
that's it like I didn't read the plot
synopsis I did nothing I just saw that
it was came up on um Hulu and I was like
oh yeah [__] I've been wanting to see
that and I'm like I'm just gonna watch
it I didn't read the description or
anything and I'm kind of glad that I
didn't because I had no idea what it was
about and I had no idea where it was
going and I really like that you know I
really like that kind of approach movies
like that if I can possibly do it like I
try not to read too much about them
because I like to kind of be surprised
you know what I mean this would
definitely surprise me because I had no
idea what was gonna happen
um yeah uh says about
yeah Sebastian Shivers is first but if
you love Cronenberg you'll dig it
yeah oh Zach says and I think she sucks
on Charlotte gainsberg's tits too oh
okay I kind of well I just heard about
that movie today
um I mean I'd heard of it before but
then I'd forgotten that she was in it
nymphomaniac I'm talking about and it's
like oh well now I might have to see
that you know what I mean because that
sounds kind of good
that seems kind of good uh subjective
perspective Collective says I definitely
can see the difference between Brandon
and David yeah I don't think
I don't know I don't know if each of
them made a movie and like they showed
it to people and polled everybody about
which one was which
I could probably tell but I'm not
entirely sure because their styles are
very similar but different enough that I
think you'd be able to tell the
difference like if he did it now you
know what I'm saying I don't know I
don't know
but
um but like I said I did actually kind
of like I got more into this one than I
did crimes of the future I really liked
Crimes of the future don't get me wrong
but I think I like this one a little bit
more this one just like sucked me right
in and I was just kind of like just
riveted like the whole time like what
the [__] is going on right now you know
what I mean I'm like the future is more
intense if you ask me though more
physical yeah that's true it's different
it's like hard to compare them I guess
but the thing about it the Wikipedia
page says that infinity pool made more
money it's opening weekend than Crimes
of the Future made its whole theatrical
run
you know what I mean I mean it didn't
make a huge amount of money it was just
like 2.7 million dollars but I mean
that's a lot for a movie like this yeah
I don't know how much it costs to make
it doesn't look it didn't look cheap
though to be honest and the
cinematography was gorgeous
like wherever they shot this but like I
I was just like watching it and like
some of the shots were just like
beautiful you know what I mean and it's
like [__] up as well I just I don't
know
uh Zach says
oh about nymphomaniac careful it's like
four and a half hours of Soul
crushingness because large partial well
yeah that's kind of his whole Mo I get
it I've seen some of his movies they are
very soul-crushing uh Zach said because
only he could make a movie that long
about a sex addict MILF
super depressing like dancer in the dark
or um what's that other one dogville did
you see that you didn't see that I don't
like depressive movies
yeah I don't think you'd like a lot of
his movies then they're like not only
depressing you're just like I think I'm
gonna kill myself now yeah it's kind of
like that but you know what I mean I
don't know I kind of dig them sometimes
but I have to be in the right mood you
know what I'm saying all right so um I
guess we'll kind of wrap it up unless
you wanted to talk about something else
no that's good you know I want to talk
about something else no all right so
um tomorrow is Monday and if you live in
the United States it's uh the Fourth of
July Eve so I actually have Tuesday off
which is which is pretty nice yeah which
means that tomorrow night when we do a
haunting Mondays I can actually like
have some drinks and maybe even get
drunk and not worry about getting up
there didn't even bother calling you to
work Monday
that's what I kind of went I was like
why didn't they just give us like a four
day weekend I don't know but you know
what I mean maybe some places did but I
don't want to get one so I got to go to
work tomorrow but I don't have to go
Tuesday so yeah so Monday tomorrow night
we're gonna do uh haunting Mondays we've
already watched the episode I already
took notes on and everything like that
so we're doing the haunted Victorian
which is season six episode four I think
it was the last uh the last episode of
season six and
the house that they that is at the
center of this episode is actually quite
famous so there is like some outside
info about it not a lot but you know
what I mean because it's been like on a
bunch of the parents subject I want to
ask a question uh want to ask something
about infinity pool but definitely don't
want to spoil it for people who haven't
seen it
yeah I wonder if anybody is gonna that's
what I mean it's like so hard to talk
about movies see I mean maybe not
everybody's like me like maybe some
people actually will go and watch
reviews before they go see a movie but
see I never do that what's the question
yeah maybe you could like maybe you
could like ask it in a way that's not I
don't know I don't know what the
question is so I don't know how
difficult that would be but it's like
yeah sometimes I'll watch reviews after
just to see like I said what other
people's perspective on it were or if
I'm doing research about it or something
like that but I never watched reviews
before I see the movie because that
seems kind of pointless to me because
like I gotta see it you know what I mean
if I want to see it I'm gonna go see it
I don't care what other people think
about it only afterward but yeah but I
mean I don't know like if you want to
ask her if you want to ask me then
either ask in the chat or you can like
ask and you can message me or something
like that we'll talk about it because I
do kind of feel like I don't know I saw
some reviewers that said they didn't
really get it or they were like oh well
we didn't know if there was like some
deeper meaning to it or something I'm
like well there was but
um and it's to be honest it seemed
pretty straightforward so I don't really
know it was you know it wasn't like the
kind of movie where it's like oh my god
what the [__] just happened like it
seemed pretty straightforward yeah it
was easy to understand like I thought it
was easy to understand like there was
like some symbol in there that could be
interpreted in a couple different ways
but not really I thought it was like
pretty cut and dried you know what I
mean oh do you think the Clones could
have been switched yeah like um that was
another possibility and I'm kind of glad
that they left that open because you
never really knew
if the James that you're following
through the movie like was that the
original James or was that a different
and somebody mentioned I think Camp guy
up there like mentioned the prestige and
I was like yeah he's kind of like the
same kind of thing where you keep making
copies of yourself and you're just kind
of like well at one point at what point
are you the copy or is like you know
who's the original person you know I
mean they're like there's no way of
knowing and so in this movie they just
leave it ambiguous you're like you don't
know if that's the same James that you
started out with or if that was or if
they switched them you know what I mean
which is another kind of [__] up layer
to it and that's kind of been the Clones
doing that making more clones right so
that so that was another like intriguing
possibility so I'm glad they didn't
watch it and it might be something like
the thing where you don't know who the
thing is right you wouldn't know when
was the when was when was
the original person switched right you
might be able to find that in that movie
if if it does that yeah and I mean this
one they they he very deliberately
leaves it so I mean when James wakes up
like after the cloning process or
whatever it's like you don't know if
that was the James that you started with
or if that was the one that they made
you know what I mean there's no way of
knowing and so I think the ambiguity
about that is like what really like
makes it good because you're just
sitting there going wait is that even
the original guy or what does that even
mean could be that they lied to him they
don't kill the Clone they kill the
original and replace you with the glow
that's what I mean so that's like
another layer of like right you see well
the clone's innocent
right but the other guy did it so he did
pay for it yeah it might be might be
some [__] like that because that seems
like that would make more sense to me
right that they'd be like they'll tell
you yeah man you know it's uh if you
have the money right the Clone can die
no you'll die and we'll replace it and
the Clone will take your place yeah no
one will be the wiser yeah
but then the Clones come out [__] up
like psychos because they're not perfect
so you just keep doing that over and
over again that might be what it what it
means yeah it's like they say they keep
making copies of these miscreants and
like they and they just get worse and
worse like they're just like yeah let's
go do some crimes you know what I mean
and then they get more and more [__]
up like as they keep watching the Clones
getting yeah executed and that might be
yeah they're watching their clones get
executed but they're clones of clones of
clones they get worse that might be what
it is they're like bad Xerox copies yeah
like after a while that's why it could
be what it is I well that see that makes
more sense to me because I know that
like I watched saw a couple of different
reviews where they were like discussing
that where they were talking about well
there's no way of know knowing like
whether that was the original guy and
like the more I think about it the more
I think that you're right that probably
that wasn't the original guy but I did
but they kind of leave that ambiguous
and I think that was a good decision
because then it'll just make you wonder
like the whole time was it just the
cloning process that like made these
people go like that because there's like
a whole bunch of people that like I said
that that go to this island and like
commit all these crimes because they
know they'll get away with it and it's
like are these even the original people
that started out with Maybe not maybe
they're just clones and clones
um yeah he said glad they left it
unanswered yeah me too I think it's
always better to like not over explain
stuff and like I said this movie was
straightforward enough on its own but I
like that it left like all these
lingering questions you know what I mean
so yeah all right so I guess we're gonna
wrap it up for today and like I said be
sure to come by tomorrow night at 7 30
p.m Eastern Standard Time where we're
gonna do a haunting Mondays we're doing
uh the haunted Victorian which firms
season six so hopefully you guys can
come and join us for that so have a good
rest of your weekend you guys and we'll
see you again tomorrow night good night